[Applause]
similar to the leaders
the way i invest is just products i use
oh because that's it
if it's like if it's just products i use
it's like oh i'm i tend to use the
products i like that work well
so it's like amazon disney i mean um
uh apple tesla it's like i go to these
things
so [ __ ] if you have popeye stock
no but i'm just saying that that's just
how and i feel comfortable because i
hate
the market this [ __ ] feels like gambling
yep but it's like if i'm going to
dabble in it at least let me just do it
with companies i feel comfortable with
yeah
and it's probably not the way i already
make the most money but i'm already
invested
dude i learned something um when i was
on vacation that's like
it's so wildly unfair but i i it's
wildly unfair but i saw kind of like how
the world works
right i don't usually go to like a fancy
resort or something like that right
like but i was at this thing and
again i spoke to very few people but
what's interesting at these resorts is
like the people that end up going there
usually have some money right and
they have some money either because it
was handed down or because they made it
and they were
themselves successful and when you sit
down with these people
who have made it and they're successful
they
share so much like information like
valuable cool
information with you just because that's
what you're talking about you're curious
you're going to talk to them
and i can't imagine how many deals have
been made
new partnerships have been built new
investment ideas have been put together
simply from being in a circle of people
who are also successful
and then you see this one class of
people continue
to go up and separate itself from poor
poor people not because they hate poor
people
but simply because they're not having
the same interactions
in this like quote-unquote safe space
where everybody
must kind of be something you know how
like a fraternity party between sorority
and fraternity like
the girls at the party know all right
the guys are in kai'sai so they can't be
that bad yeah and the guys know okay the
girls are in dg so they can't be
so everybody kind of feels more
comfortable talking yeah and i'm like
i as valuable as it is having these
conversations and just like
learning this stuff i also i'm like oh
man it's so unfair
that's what makes podcasts amazing like
yeah jurgen podcast
shepard experts on experts right these
are you're just bringing on
brilliant people and then they're just
talking sharing information
that happened at country clubs for years
and for the first time in history the
average person like us
is able to listen in on like a [ __ ]
super scientist
never been accessible to us because the
country club is an exceptional wow you
had to literally go to school
to have access to some of these
brilliant people yeah and
it's i mean i was talking this one guy
and he's invested in a genome
uh research yeah and what they've found
what they can do now
you know that they can remove the genome
no they can remove the part of your dna
that gives you sickle cell four black
people they can go in there and
change that piece of dna there's a i
think it's
interesting there's a company called
crisp on it right that's the one i'm
gonna say yeah yeah
and what there is is there's this thing
i'm gonna learn a little bit more and
try invest in it but
uh it's a basically a fund that
invests in like the top 15 of these
genome companies so
two or three of them will end up popping
and then you do well but what he was
breaking down to me is
they can go in and fix impurities in our
dna
so for example let's say you have some
crippling illness like uh
als or something like that they can go
into your dna
and replace that park yep that's what
they're working on right now they can't
do it
through and through and also there's
ethical problems which is like i want my
kid to be this tall
or whatever rich people get to change
all their dna yes
so the the bad part is rich people get
to change all their dna and increase
that gap
but the good part is my dad who's got
[ __ ] alzheimer's if he
lasts another six to ten years they
might be able to [ __ ] go in there and
fix that part of his dna yeah
i think uh i couldn't believe it the
human genome project is one of the big
ones that does it
but then in uh harare's book he talks
about there's a
uh what he calls like a dna artist or
some [ __ ] yep is this
a brazilian dude that took a rabbit and
swapped out one of the one of the
strands of the dna to make it
glow under ultraviolet light
and so like in any part of nature like
being able to glow at night is like the
worst thing you can do
yeah like if you're like a land creature
or whatever yeah but that he was able to
swap this piece of
the rabbit was like it didn't glow yeah
no so it did ah so it did so
he was taking like uh like uh what they
call it not chlorophyll but like
whatever the uh
like uh cetaphil
no but like whatever like the jellyfish
in the ocean used
bioluminescence yup he took that gene
put in a rabbit and then it glowed green
and so he was actually able to like
alter
the visual appearance of this rabbit and
he was like we could do it to people we
could do it to anything
and that was in like 2004. that's and so
here's the thing
obviously there's ethical concerns and
you know we don't know what the
long-term effects will be
but the guy said to me this guy who has
he was an eye doctor but he also
invested in these companies and that was
his big thing there
and i'd only get to have this
conversation because we're both sitting
at the same
snorkeling thing right yeah
i can help you not drown yeah you can
have gills
i went to i i literally he's telling me
he's like
in the next 10 years we should be able
to
increase life expectancy to 150 years
if you can make it the next 10. now
again who knows akash said we will have
flying cars in three years we're like
there's no [ __ ] way we're gonna have
it
again but same book talked about all
this stuff actually
idiot but it was a pretty cool thing and
maybe i have false hope obviously
because i have you know
people in my life affected by illness
that like it's just gonna
eventually kill them right which is what
it is or they end up dying
but um i mean imagine in our [ __ ]
lifetime
mm-hmm i think it's gonna be nuts
this is right here if they're already if
it's not perfect but they're there how
long until they're there and then when
that's there
babies are whatever you want them to be
within 10-15 years it's like [ __ ]
nose jobs like you didn't see those back
in the day and then everybody started
doing it yeah now
there's a like kind of a weird like
ethical dilemma that comes with it not
even like ethical but like a social
like implication that comes with it yep
so let's say they're able to increase
life expectancy
yep but they're not able to cure or like
prevent
like mortality so you can live to be 150
200
but you're still susceptible to the same
things that an average human is
susceptible to
so like if you're in a car accident
you're still just as likely to die yep
are people
less are people less likely to take
risks
in their personal life both like
financially both literally with like
their bodies like
yup are people less uh are they more
risk averse
uh explain the argument for why they are
because
i think conventionalism will be like i
think what the difference be
i think what he's trying to say is
they're saying life is short whatever do
they do this that's not true anymore
life
is longest it's twice as long as it used
to be right i guess
what i would say to that is that it's
already long
yeah it's kind of what i know when we
were maybe living 40 years maybe it was
a little bit more gung-ho
and [ __ ] it i'll just take this sword
and i'll run into this group of people
what to his point yeah we life
expectancies increased from like [ __ ]
25 to
75 but that didn't happen within our
lifetime that happened over
centuries this could happen within 10
years so we go from living to 75 to 150
well [ __ ] this is a different way to
look at somebody bring this conversation
full circle
from the beginning of the podcast what i
was feeling was avoiding risk
yeah my whole life i've been risky it's
it's
been very beneficial to me yeah but i i
got to a point where i was like
well this is pretty nice like you know i
got people i care about and i love and
i people i'm responsible for
i i it's selfish of me to risk yeah
am i being a self i'm not being selfish
maybe you're right
yeah like you're 17 you have like no
bills like no rent no kids like yeah
i'll go do whatever i'll go skydive rock
climb like
i'll be drunk and jump on this train as
it's passing by you don't give a [ __ ]
but then as soon as you have life and
all of a sudden now you're 50 and you're
like yo i have 100 more years i can live
like if you're 50 you're like i might
die when i'm 70. right now when i'm 75.
like i have a whatever i can't go skiing
until i'm 90. that's what i'm saying
i can't yeah i'll do that when i'm 100.
yeah
then you still have 50 years on top of
that i still think that boredom will
overtake most people and i think they'll
go after these certain
things just to create some sort of like
distraction but is the loss
greater considering like if someone dies
when they're 70 we go yeah you know he
lived a good life
you die when you're 70 in 10 years that
wow that's so sad that will change but i
don't think
our taking risks will change i think
taking risks will change depending on
the success in your life but i do think
the sadness at a lost life
will be dependent on the percentage of
his life that could be lived
right just like it is now when a 30 year
old dies we go oh my god he was so young
i would love for us to get to a point
where if a hundred year old person dies
we go
yeah there's so much life
i want to look like one of them cuban
cars you know you go to havana
and the outside look fire but the
inside's held with duct tape
through me like that
you